We'll start with our general case. We'll have one person completing one job in
a hours and another person completing that same job in b hours. This means that
their total time together would be x hours. And 1 over x would be the fraction
of the job done together in one hour. We know x in this case would be 2 and 4
10ths hours. Since this is the total amount of time it takes them to edit the
film together. Now, we need expressions for these two. If we let x equal the
time it takes Carlos to edit, we can use x in one of the denominators. We know
Melissa takes two hours longer than Carlos, so we can just add two to x to get
x plus 2 for Melissa's time. Great thinking if you found this equation. I know
it's not easy.